ein jahr lang arbeitete sandra m in
einer kita in kempen dort soll es zu
vier ähnlichen vorfällen mit einem
zweijährigen jungen gekommen sein ich
möchte nun darüber sprechen mit dem
bürgermeister von kempenaers mir live
zugeschaltet völker rio kontakt zu
nehmen sagte die stadt kempen
zunächst hatte die stadt kempten
dementiert dass es zu vorfällen in
zusammenhang mit sandra m der
tatverdächtigen kam warum wir haben
nicht dementiert dass es zu einem fall
hier in captain gekommen ist
wir haben ausgeführt dass es keinen
konkreten anlass für ermittlungen
gegeben hat es ist ein kind hier in
kempten betroffen gewesen was viermal in
die kinderklinik nach viersen gebracht
werden musste mit atemnot
die ärzte haben nichts feststellen
können haben das kind also umfassend
untersucht
die aussage war wir können nichts
feststellen kein fremdverschulden
insoweit hatten wir keinen anders hier
ermittlungen anzustellen interner art es
hat auch keine ermittlungen natürlich
deshalb auch von polizei oder
staatsanwaltschaft gegeben das haben wir
mitgeteilt wir hatten allerdings auch
die auflage von seiten der
staatsanwaltschaft nicht weitergehend zu
informieren die öffentlichkeit weil die
staatsanwaltschaft und die polizei
natürlich hier ihre ermittlungen zum
abschluss bringen wollen und sie captain
sind diese ermittlungen ja auch noch
nicht zum abschluss gebracht worden
das hat ja gestern die
staatsanwaltschaft und die polizei in
ihrer pressekonferenz dargestellt also
insoweit finden hier noch ergänzende
untersuchungen statt
ich möchte aber auch die gelegenheit
nutzen meine tief empfundene anteilnahme
auszudrücken der familie von kreta der
tod eines kindes schmerz grenzenlos und
unermesslich wird natürlich der schmerz
wenn sich dann herausstellt dass das
geliebte kind ermordet worden ist und so
geht es sicherlich jetzt auch den eltern
der kinder die von der erzieherin
misshandelt worden sind die natürlich
jetzt auch in großer sorge sind
und sicherlich darunter leiden dass
möglicherweise auch ihr kind das
schicksal von kreta hätten erleiden
können das macht fassungslos und sie
merkt dann auch mehr an dass mir gerade
auch die pressekonferenz gestern die
ergebnisse die die polizei und die
staatsanwaltschaft vorgetragen hat dass
diese ergebnisse ganz ganz tief gehen
und natürlich auch zu großer unruhe bei
eltern führen sagen sie genau diesen
eltern sie hatten die vier vorfälle auch
angesprochen
damals konnte nicht festgestellt werden
ob es fremdverschulden gab aber sandra m
war immer vor ort wenn der kleine junge
ins krankenhaus aufgrund von atemnot
musste ist sie vorher nicht schon
aufgefallen beispielsweise durch
arbeitszeugnis mehrere arbeitgeber
sollen gesagt haben sie ist nicht
geeignet für den job einer erzieherin
sie die erzieherin ist jetzt ja nach
ihrem anerkennungsjahr hier bei der
stadt kerpen angefangen das war ihre
erste stelle die sie nach ihrem
staatsexamen also übernommen hat nach
ihrer anerkennung als staatlich
anerkannte erzieherin
wir hatten hier das berufsschulzeit war
wir hatten das führungszeugnis vorlegen
als insoweit gab es keinen anlass sie
hier nicht bei uns anzustellen
sie haben auch gerade die
pressekonferenz bereits angesprochen
warum waren niemand von den städten in
denen es zu diesen vorfällen kamen vor
ort bei der pressekonferenz
wir wären gerne bei der pressekonferenz
gewesen hatten uns auch angemeldet aber
die pressekonferenz war bereits
ausgebucht so haben wir uns das gestern
hier die live-berichterstattung auf n-tv
im rathaus angesehen zusammen mit dem
jugenddezernenten mit der anleitung des
jugendamtes und haben dann eben
fassungslos wirklich gehört dass es
nicht nur in vier sind nicht nur in
kempten sondern auch in tönisvorst und
auch in krefeld während ihres
anerkennung des jahres zu vorfällen
gekommen ist eine letzte frage die kita
soll natürlich der ort sein an dem
kinder aller sichersten sind eltern die
kinder dorthin vertrauen darauf dass sie
sie am abend oder nachmittag gesund
wieder zurück bekommen was sagen sie
jetzt den eltern was wird sich jetzt
ändern damit sie trotzdem sich in
sicherheit für in ihre kinder jetzt
wieder in der betreuung abzugeben
wir werden mit allen eltern die jetzt
sorgen haben gespräche führen dieses
angebot steht unsere
einrichtungsleitungen unsere
erzieherinnen unser jugendamt stehen zur
verfügung um also vertrauen bei den
eltern herzustellen ihnen hilfe
anzubieten
ich glaube ein solcher vorfall wie wir
ihn jetzt erleben ist kaum zu verhindern
wenn eine erzieherin offensichtlich auch
mit medizinischem wissen sich in einer
weise an kindern vergeht wo es keine
nachweise gibt wo es also keine fremde
einwirkung spuren gibt dann ist das fast
nicht zu verhindern glaube ich